by popular request we're going to be
pitting two of the most prominent
phablets against each other an iPhone 6
plus vs. a galaxy note for those of you
who don't know a phablet is a
combination of the words phone and
tablet because their phones with giant
tablet like screens are they tablets
with tiny phone light screens Wow
with its large retina HD display and
power efficiency the iPhone 6 plus is
one of Apple's most innovative iPhones
yet if by innovative you mean a ripoff
of the galaxy note then sure it's real
innovative this baby has a higher
resolution screen adaptive fast charging
and a sweet stylus pen but which one can
take the most abuse to the leg I'm
thinking the note 4 just because I have
one haha I think it's gonna do better
uh-huh yeah because I'm gonna throw the
iPhone harder at the ground I mean you
like your iPhone right I do I'm gonna
get one of those when my contract allows
roll action
now the note 4 has the removable back so
I think it's meant to happen
okay I'm gonna gum in the ghost my boy
first how's it look
oh but still totally working but look
totally popped off I think I could pop
it back but I'm not gonna do it just yet
okay well how does my if my screen is
cracked I'm no screen fine oh your
camera's cracked that's a big part of
the phone I mean it's not like an
Instagram filter anyway it's like artsy
what's next we're gonna bring out the
throne alright bring up the phone we've
all been there you're doing your
business after just having dropped your
phone from 15 feet in the air and you
accidentally drop your phone in the
toilet well we're gonna find out how
long each of these phablets can hold
their breaths
wrong
action
okay
still going
Greenup oh wow that was eight and a half
seconds we're so quick and so sad I'm
going in I mean what do you think
someone's reaction time if they drop the
phone in the toilet it's going to be
close probably about two seconds water's
warm feel nothing grosser than reaching
into toilet water in it being warm I'm
confident going to be eight seconds if
it's less than eight seconds I'm gonna
be calling Samsung I'm a piss roll
action
okay still on still on salon looks fine
which is totally fine I've been fading
looks looks great actually
it's sitting there perch beautifully in
the toilet and I think I already lost
certainly been defeated I mean you've
already I've already won but let's see
I'm shocked I mean oh there we go with
that we had 34 second 34 seconds so you
could accidentally drop your phone in
the toilet go make a sandwich come back
get your phone Galaxy Note 4 owners
don't worry you got time you must make
really crappy sandwiches alright we're
going up to drop B shame safe oh I'm
still ready to do this roll action
you know they say the iPhones Bend I
guess the right it doesn't look that bad
actually I think it just fell forward I
can't believe that no no I think it's a
five shame it's too proud you just
another our phones are destroyed we can
finally have like a real conversation
like we used to
you're right it's gonna be great
you